do I feel like a failure as a mom like
500% YouTube star Micah Stauffer is
opening up about her controversial
decision to rehome her adopted son
Huxley anything that happened in the
home that was hard for Huck's
that's not fair for me to put out there
publicly that's his privacy it's been
almost one month since Micah and her
husband James shared the news of their
difficult decision on YouTube now the
mom of four biological children is
issuing an apology to her fans in a
lengthy post shared on Instagram
Wednesday the 33 year old takes full
responsibility for the hurt she caused
quote this decision has caused so many
people heartbreak and I'm sorry for
letting down so many women that looked
up to me as a mother Micah called
herself naive when starting the adoption
process adding that she was not
selective or fully equipped or prepared
and while she says the experience has
been hard she added that she's still
glad it happened because Huxley has been
given a new chance at life after being
brought from China to America in 2017
quote I also know that even though he is
happier in his new home and doing better
that he still experienced trauma and I'm
sorry no adoptee deserves any more
trauma Micah also shot down the rumors
that they adopted Huxley to gain wealth
writing that while they did receive some
money from videos featuring Huxley every
penny and much more went back into his
care she concluded the post writing that
they loved Huxley and know it was the
right decision for him and his future
here we've never wanted to be in this
position and we've been trying to get
him get his needs met and help him out
as much as possible
here we truly welcome back in May the
couple announced the news that their son
was no longer living with them in an
emotional YouTube video numerous medical
professionals have felt that he needed a
different thing his medical needs he
needed more in a blog post from April
2019 mica said the adoption agency
initially told the couple that Huxley
had been diagnosed with a brain cyst and
that he had a small brain tumor but that
it didn't affect his cognitive abilities
but when they brought him home
she said he was profoundly
developmentally delayed and displayed
behavior like violently banging his head
against the wall
Mike explained that after seeing
multiple specialists he was diagnosed
with autism spectrum disorder level 3
once Huxley came home there was a lot
more special needs that we weren't aware
of and that we were not told so over the
past few years
Huxley's been in numerous therapies to
try to help him with all of his needs
since the Stauffer shared that video in
late May mica who spent years
documenting the adoption process has
lost more than twenty thousand YouTube
subscribers and she's received a lot of
online criticism when he get like
insidious hurtful comments it just like
really makes it worse
now Michael writes that she's praying
that Huxley only has the best future in
the entire world
they found somebody that they felt would
be ultimately the best fit and he is
thriving he is very happy he's doing
really well and his new mommy has
medical professional training and it is
a very good fit
[Music]